a french appeals court has ruled that
the man accused of funding the rwandan
genocide
can be handed over to a united nations
tribunal
in tanzania felizan kabuga's lawyers had
wanted him to be tried in france where
he was arrested
he faces charges of genocide and crimes
against humanity relating to the horrors
in rwanda during which 800 000 people
were killed in 1994.
here's more about felisan kabuga
the businessman made much of his wealth
from tea farming
felicia and kabuga had strong links to
the former rwandan president juvenal
haberimana
and the then ruling nrmd party dominated
by the hutu
ethnic group kabuki is accused of
setting up
and providing funds for the hutu militia
that carried out
massacres against rival tutsi people and
moderate hutus
he also founded a notorious radio
station that played a key role
in inciting the genocide
a wanted man kabuka evaded arrest for
years
in africa and europe despite reports of
him being cited in different countries
after he was eventually arrested in
paris in may
he appeared before france's supreme
court there
his lawyer said he was in poor health
and in no condition to be tried
elsewhere
and i am now joined by serge brahmetz he
is the chief prosecutor for the
international residual mechanism for
criminal tribunals that is the
international tribunal
handling the rondon genocide trials
welcome to dw
news africa mr branvitz uh feliciano
kabunga
uh wanted to be tried in france your
preference was that he be tried at the
un's tribunal
in tanzania what is the significance of
where the trial takes place
good afternoon in fact it is not the
question of of preference
it's a question about jurisdiction when
the
raunder when the rwanda tribunal closed
a few years ago the residual
competencies were given to the mechanism
especially in relation to the three
remaining main fugitives and kabuka is
one of those three
so based on the statute of the mechanism
which has been put in place by the
security council
today the mechanism is the only
competent jurisdiction to deal with the
kabuka case
okay so you say it is the competent
jurisdiction but mr kabuka has said
through his lawyers
that a u.n court in africa would be
biased
against him is it your view that he is
guaranteed a fair trial
at the u.n tribunal in africa
there's absolutely no doubt about this
you know the
rwanda tribunal and the mechanism is
operating for more than 20 years
there have been dozens and dozens of of
cases our judges are international
judges coming from different parts of
the world
same for the investigators and
prosecutors it is a united
nations tribunal with all the
independence and impartiality
necessary to make sure that it will be a
fair trial
mr brahmos this is a very important case
for the people of rwanda
um and if memory serves me correct
president
paul kagame of rwanda has at some point
hinted that
justice would be better served if mr
booger would be tried in rwanda
in the event that kigali requests to
have mr kabuga tried in rwanda and i
understand that that is a decision that
the u.n security council
would have to make but do you have any
reservations about that
for mr kabuga to be tried in rwanda
no personally i have absolutely no
reservations
in this regard you know in in general
terms as an international prosecutor
i'm always in favor of having
trials taking place in the country where
crimes have been
committed where the victims communities
are living but also where the
perpetrator community is living so where
it is
possible i've always been being
supportive that trials are taking place
at the national level now today this
question of course is not uh on the
agenda if i may say because
um it has been a fugitive
of justice for the rwanda tribunal now
for the mechanism
we have the legal authority to
have this trial taking place at the the
mechanism and we are
absolutely ready to move this trial uh
forward of course if there would be a
decision
by the security council deciding to
change the mandate
as prosecutor well we are updating our
case file and we
follow what uh is decided what is
important
is that a trial is taking place what is
important
is that the victims and survivors will
be hurt
and for me personally um this is the
main
issue not if the trial is taking place
in in arusha or in kigali
okay and are you confident that you're
going to secure a guilty
verdict um recently you were on a
fact-finding mission
in rwanda what can you tell us about
that
well it will be up to to judges to
decide at the end of the trial about
guilt or innocence as prosecutors
of course you know this investigation
started in the 90s
the restaurant is from 97 of course my
predecessors had already collected
evidence
if not no international restaurant or
indictment would be
issued or confirmed now obviously the
case
is has not been active if i may say for
for many years so it's absolutely normal
that as often of the prosecutor
we are updating the existing case file
but we are also looking for additional
evidence to strengthen the the case
uh so i was myself in in kigali
uh only three weeks ago for for two
weeks uh i have in fact
um a permanent team there which would be
there for a number of months it's not
just
effect finding it is really a minimum
for the next six months if not longer
that i will have um several prosecutors
investigators analysts
um in kigali
contacting witnesses which have
testified in the past
updating um information looking for
additional evidence
but it's the the normal way to proceed
if an arrest is taking place many many
years after
the indictment was issued right so the
rest takes place many years after the
indictment issued
what kind of a time span are we looking
at for the actual
trial very briefly if you can
well it's it's up to the judges once a
trial chamber has been
been determined and and put together
now what i can tell you is that based on
on previous cases
with uh with arrests taking place at the
rwanda tribunal yusuf tribunal
most often it takes up to one year
between uh the
the transfer of the the um individual to
the mechanism
and the start of the trial so we will
definitely not see
a trial starting uh somewhere this year
all right that's serge rametz thank you
for that sir
you're almost right